do you remember when that mod team  worked to bring GTA fours Liberty City  into GTA 5 s map well it's happening  again I'm Tony and this is your Wild  West game spot news update if you can't  wait for Red Dead Redemption - you'll be  happy to know that a group of fans are  modding the entirety of the first games  map into gta5 this will drop all the  territories textures and day/night cycle  right next to los santos at some point  the team also wants to port over Red  Dead Redemption actual missions and  mechanics but that's a long-term goal  for now the modders plan to release the  map expansion this summer so hit that  subscribe button to be the first to know  when it goes live as for Red Dead  Redemption 2 itself Rockstar says the  anticipated sequel is slated for release  this fall but for more gun slinging  action right now why not check out our  guide for over watches newest hero Arisa  [Music]